[Music]
matt is in pittsburgh hey matt welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave it's an honor to be speaking
with you today you too what's up
um well i'm currently a 22 year old
college student um i'll be graduating
here in the next couple months and i'm
looking to get out of my renting
situation and purchase a home within the
next year i'm kind of lost on how to
really save up for it if i should be
keeping all my um
like income that i'm going to be having
in cash or if i should be investing it
and how much you recommend to put down
on my first home purchase i'm just kind
of looking for some guidance here cool
so what's your income matt
um well currently i don't have any but
i'll be starting a job in june that um
i'll be making uh 70 000 in my first
year plus um 10k in stock but i'm pretty
sure i don't get paid that until like a
year year and a half okay
and do you have any debt right now
um i have i have a good amount of
savings and personal investments but i
do have nine thousand dollars left on a
car payment okay and that's all the debt
that's all that so what's stopping you
from paying off the car today
and freeing up that payment um
i well i um
i i was fortunate enough not to have to
pay for my college because i got an
athletic scholarship so because of that
um my dad we bought a car together well
it's in my name but we bought it
together during covid so there's um no
interest on it it was like one of those
deals i know
you probably won't like hearing that but
uh i don't know i just haven't put it as
a first priority just because i don't
really want to use my um i have about
like 11 000 in savings right now and i
kind of don't have an income these next
couple months so i've just been avoiding
it i guess how much have you gotten
personal investments
um around 17.
okay and is that in a retirement account
uh no it's actually in individual stocks
and yeah basically all stocks and a
little bit of cryptocurrency
okay well matt i'll tell you what we
teach and this is the process i followed
to get through all the baby steps and
now with a paid for house baby step one
is a thousand dollar emergency fund baby
step two we pay off all of our debt
using the debt snowball method and that
includes the car baby step three we get
three to six months of expenses and an
emergency fund and then baby step three
b we start saving up for the house
and so that's where that would fall in
and so you're not quite there yet you
could be
if we released these investments cashed
out and started doing things a different
way
but it sounds like you're you're good
with matt's plan which is fine but if
you're going to buy a house here's our
parameters for it in that 3b i want you
to save up 10 to 20
for your down payment on a 15-year fixed
mortgage that should be your only option
when it comes to mortgages and the take
your uh payment on that should be no
more than a quarter of your take-home
pay
so you can jump onto our mortgage
calculator ramseysolutions.com and start
playing around with those numbers
to see hey in the pittsburgh area for a
reasonable house for me for you know my
my first house what do i need to do okay
i need to save up seventy thousand
dollars in order to get this house on a
15-year fixed rate where the payments no
more than a quarter of my take home pay
gotcha i'm at your so once i pay off the
car
sorry what was that go ahead go ahead
so once uh once i pay up the car and
save enough for to put 20 percent down
and my take-home pay it's my monthly
payments a quarter of my take-home pay
then i'm good to go
on a 15-year yeah and you could i mean
today if you paid off the car you'd
still have money left over for your
emergency fund and then you can start to
save up for this down payment we just
got to start doing things in the right
order so that you feel this progress
gotcha okay so here's the thing
um
you've listened to this show i can tell
by the way you're responding to some of
these things
and you kind of knew what we were going
to say didn't you
yeah a little bit
all right and so
here's the data
the actual facts
not theory
not a ramsey opinion but the actual
facts we did the largest study
of millionaires ever done in north
america 10 167 of them
the number of them that became
millionaires using bitcoin was precisely
zero
the number of them that used single
stocks playing
a day trader game
was
under five percent
in other words 95 of them did not use
your plan
right
so you need to decide if your plan sucks
as bad as i think it does
well would you recommend cashing out of
my individual stocks in crypto and
keeping that apparently
apparently that's what i just told you
so don't invest that in anything else
keep it sitting in cash
you need an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and you need to
be debt-free paying off that stupid car
by the end of the day
and then you start then you start
building in cash
your down payment on your house
and then when you get your house you
start putting 15 percent of your income
away into good growth stock mutual funds
in your 401k at your new great job and
you're going to be a millionaire doing
that by the time you're 35
and you're gonna have your house paid
off by the time you're 35. if
you follow
what we teach
that is a proven
process a proven plan that data backs up
it's not doing what your broke friends
all think is sexy while you guys are
playing beer pong
this is what is really done by real
millionaires